This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Happy New Year, beautiful nerds. It's 2024 and it is many stories volume 18. To ease this into the New Year, we have stories of buildings constructed from the sky to the ground, the little filler words that convey nothing and everything at the same time, and a song about a fire that never goes on. Let's do it.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美丽的书呆子们，新年快乐。2024年到了，这是第18卷精彩故事。为了让大家轻松迎接新年，我们准备了从天而空到地面建造的建筑、那些同时表达了什么也没说却又说明了一切的微小填充词，以及一首关于一场永不熄灭的大火的歌。我们开始吧。
So I'm here with Colestead, Digital Director and co-author of the 99% Invisible City, and you are here to tell us about the newest, most unlikely craze in skyscraper construction. What do you got? Yeah, well, we've already covered a lot of different ways of putting up and taking down buildings on the show and in our book. And you know, there's bottom up construction and there's both top down and bottom up demolition, which are pretty fascinating. But now there's actually something in that fourth quadrant of building that I don't think we've ever talked about before and that's top down construction
所以我今天请到了科尔·斯泰德，他是《99%隐形城市》的数字总监兼合著者，你今天是来跟我们讲讲摩天大楼建造中最最新、最让人意想不到的热潮的。你带来了什么？是的，嗯，我们在节目和书中已经探讨过很多种搭建和拆除建筑物的方法了。你知道的，有自下而上的建造，还有自上而下和自下而上的拆除，这些都非常迷人。但现在，在建筑学的第四个象限里，其实出现了一种我认为我们以前从未讨论过的东西，那就是自上而下的建造。
Okay, you're gonna have to break this down for me because I can't imagine how you build a skyscraper from the top Yeah, yeah, good question. So there's this new tower in Detroit, which is a great example. This is called Exchange, and its levels were built in reverse order. The top floor first and the ground floor last. Here's a photo that kind of shows you how this is working, like midway through the construction process. Okay, I see. So it kind of looks like the top half of a skyscraper, but with legs on it. So I gather that these thick concrete pillars are kind of holding up to top half of a skyscraper, but with legs on it. So I gather that these thick concrete pillars are kind of holding up the top half of the skyscraper.
好吧，你得给我详细解释一下，因为我无法想象你怎么能从顶部开始建造一座摩天大楼。是啊，是啊，问得好。底特律有一座新大厦就是一个很好的例子。这座大厦名叫“交易大厦”（Exchange），它的楼层是以相反的顺序建造的：最顶层最先建造，底层最后建造。这里有一张照片，展示了它在建造过程进行到一半时是如何运作的。好吧，我明白了。所以它看起来有点像摩天大楼的上半部分，但带有支腿。我想这些厚厚的混凝土柱子大概支撑着摩天大楼的上半部分。
Yeah, that's exactly right. And part of what I find so fascinating about this is that that it's a clients, it looks really uncanny. Like we're not used to seeing skyscrapers being held up primarily on a couple of spindly legs, but that's not a reflection of a really big structural difference in how this works versus other skyscrapers. It really is a function of what we normally see and don't see in the construction process. So underneath it all, this actually works much more
对，完全正确。我发现最迷人的地方之一在于，从客户的角度来看，它看起来真的很诡异。我们不习惯看到摩天大楼主要靠几根细长的腿支撑着，但这并不反映这种建筑与其他摩天大楼在结构上有很大的根本区别。这其实只是我们在建造过程中通常能看到和看不到的东西的一种体现。所以在这一切的表象之下，它的运作方式实际上更像……
like a normal skyscraper than you might imagine. Okay. What do you mean? Right. So the big difference in construction technology is like framing cladding versus masonry. And masonry is how we've built for most of our history. And when you're building with masonry units like bricks or stones, you start at the ground level and you stack upward, right? Masonry walls end up supporting their own weight and the weight of whatever's above them. Sky scrapers work fundamentally differently. In those, the exterior walls clearly aren't structural, right? Like you don't hold things up with glass. Instead, what's holding up the building are internal elements, like steel reinforced concrete columns, or in the case of this top-down tower, a steel reinforced pair of concrete
……更像你可能想象中的普通摩天大楼。好的。这是什么意思？没错。建筑技术上的巨大差异在于框架式幕墙与砖石结构。砖石结构是我们大部分历史中采用的建造方式。当你用砖块或石头等砖石单元建造时，你是从地面开始向上堆砌的，对吧？砖石墙最终要承受它们自身的重量以及它们上方任何东西的重量。摩天大楼的运作方式根本不同。在摩天大楼中，外墙显然不是承重结构，对吧？比如你不会用玻璃来支撑重物。相反，支撑建筑的是内部元素，比如钢筋混凝土柱，或者在这个自上而下的塔楼的案例中，是一对钢筋混凝土……
circulation cores. And each floor is built around these vertical supports. And in the end, the whole exterior is just a wrapping of metal and glass that make up these walls that shield us from the elements. They're not holding up things. Right. So even though the process of building this particular top-down building reveals its legs, so to speak, every skyscraper has those legs. That's really what holds
……交通核心筒。每一层都是围绕着这些垂直支撑建造的。最后，整个外观只是金属和玻璃的包裹层，构成了这些为我们遮风挡雨的墙壁。它们并不承重。对吧？所以，尽管建造这座特殊的自上而下的建筑的过程暴露了它的“腿”（可以这么说），但每一座摩天大楼都有那些“腿”。这才是真正支撑……
us a skyscraper up. However, you built it. Pretty much, yeah, like most skyscrapers have cores of some kind that work like these still legs. Like they offer structural support in the house circulation, meaning staircases and elevator shafts. But in the typical skyscraper, of some kind that work like these still legs, like they offer structural support and they have circulation, meaning staircases and elevator shafts, but in a typical skyscraper, you might also have smaller columns spread out across each floor, helping further distribute loads. And if you're building floor by floor, that's a pretty easy way to do things, right? You build one floor, you add an array of columns to support the next and so on and so forth. But in this top down case where you're lifting each floor up, that would be a huge pain
……无论你如何建造，都能撑起摩天大楼的东西。差不多是这样，对吧，大多数摩天大楼都有某种核心筒，它们就像这些静止的柱子一样工作。它们提供结构支撑并设有交通空间，也就是楼梯间和电梯井。但在典型的摩天大楼中，你可能还会在每一层分布着更小的柱子，以进一步分散荷载。如果你是一层一层地建造，那是一种相当简单的方法，对吧？你建造一层，添加一排柱子来支撑下一层，以此类推。但在这种每一层都被提升上来的自上而下的情况下，那将是一个巨大的麻烦。
because each built on the ground level has to be raised around any vertical supports that go all the way up, right? And it's easier to just have these two big pant holes for those two legs in each level than have tons of smaller holes for each and every little support. Huh. And so in the end, it really does look like a normal tower. Like when it's done, you wouldn't know how it was constructed.
因为在地面上建造的每一层都必须围绕着一直延伸到顶部的任何垂直支撑进行提升，对吧？每层楼只为那两条腿开两个大洞，比起为每一个小支撑开无数个更小的洞，要简单得多。哈。所以最后，它看起来确实像一座普通的塔楼。当它完工时，你根本不知道它是怎么建造的。
Yeah. Yeah. So then why? I guess it's cool. Yeah. But why? Well, safety is like one of their big arguments for this because instead of sending people up onto these high floors, which you know start without walls, the walls are already there when the floors get lifted into place. So there's no way for like a worker on a high floor to fall off the building. Right.
是啊。是啊。那为什么呢？我想这很酷。对吧。但为什么要这么做呢？嗯，安全是他们支持这种做法的一大理由，因为不用把工人派到那些高层去（这些高层你知道的一开始是没有墙的），当楼层被吊装到位时，墙壁已经建好了。所以高层工人根本没有从大楼上掉下去的可能。对吧。
Similarly, you've got all these odds and ends and processes that go on typically up high, like, cranes lifting stuff into place, and all of that can now happen on the ground, which means, again, it's like, you're not gonna have something dropped from a crane on your head. But there must be some kind of complication with lifting an entire done floor up the line. Like, what are we talking about? Like, how much are they even way?
同样，你也有了通常在高处进行的各种零散杂务和工序，比如起重机把东西吊装到位，所有这些现在都可以在地面上进行了。这意味着，还是那句话，你不会遇到被起重机掉落的东西砸到头的情况。但是，把一整层已经建好的楼层一路吊装上去，肯定会有一些复杂的问题吧？比如，我们在说什么？它们到底有多重？
Well, about a million pounds each. So yeah, it's not an easy task, right? Like it's very tricky. And what they did is they used these things called strand jacks. Now I could nerd out about this technology for a while, but suffice it to say a strand jack is a hydraulic lift system that gets used
嗯，大约每块一百万磅。所以是的，这不是一件容易的事，对吧？这非常棘手。他们所做的是使用了一种叫做“钢绞线千斤顶”的东西。现在，我可以就这项技术大谈特谈好一阵子，但简单来说，钢绞线千斤顶是一种液压提升系统，当……
when nothing else will do. And they have enough power to pull and lift things like oil rigs, which weigh tens of thousands of tons each. So like if it gets built on shore, they can drag it off shore with strand jacks. And so you would hook up the strand jacks to these sort of concrete stilt legs and they just kind of pull up each for. Yeah. And that highlights another advantage of this approach too, because by raising things straight
……其他方法都不起作用时就会被派上用场。它们有足够的动力来拉动和提升诸如石油钻井平台之类重达数万吨的庞然大物。所以如果它是在岸上建造的，他们可以用钢绞线千斤顶把它拖到离岸。所以你会把钢绞线千斤顶连接到这种混凝土高跷腿上，然后它们就把每一层拉上去。对吧？是的，这也凸显了这种方法的另一个优势，因为通过将物体笔直向上提升，……
up, you reduce the need for the construction site to spread horizontally. Like normally you'd have a lot of stuff going on around the building, right? You'd have cranes and they'd have to be like across the street possibly and all of that stuff takes up space and in this particular case space was really at a premium and they couldn't build it that way. So this was really in part a site specific solution. And there are elements of this that are not new like lifting pre-fabricated elements into place is something we've done for a while. This is just no pun intended, taking things to the next level. So, you know, lifting not just wall panels and boxes and things, but like entire completed floors. I'm pretty sure that pun was intended, so but I'm going to allow it.
……你减少了建筑工地向水平方向延伸的需求。通常情况下，你的大楼周围会有很多事情在同时进行，对吧？你会配备起重机，它们甚至可能得横跨街道，所有这些东西都会占用空间。而在这种特殊情况下，空间真的极其宝贵，他们无法那样建造。所以这在某种程度上是一个因地制宜的解决方案。而且其中有些元素并不新鲜，比如把预制构件吊装到位是我们一直在做的事情。这只是（双关语，虽然我无意抖机灵）把事情提升到了一个新的高度。所以，你知道的，不仅仅是吊装墙板、箱体之类的东西，而是吊装整层完工的楼层。我敢肯定那个双关语是故意的，但我接受它。
Okay, it might have been. So you mentioned the site specific one in Detroit, to solve the problem, not being able to spread out. But is this really going to be like the next big thing? Like are we going to be hearing about this? Like I hear about mass timber or something like that? I am not sure. I personally love all of this, but it's one of those like all tools have specific uses
好吧，也许是的。所以你提到了底特律那个因地制宜的例子，为了解决无法向外扩展的问题。但这真的会成为下一个大热点吗？我们以后还会听到关于它的消息吗？就像我听到关于重型木结构之类的消息那样？我不太确定。我个人非常喜欢所有这些，但它属于那种“每种工具都有特定用途”的东西。
thing. So I would expect to see this happen more on tight urban sites. I would imagine this will be used more and more over time. That makes sense. So I have one final question. I imagine the advantage of building things from the ground up is you're starting where the ground is. So you don't have to calculate where the building meets the ground. It just happens naturally. You know, but how big of a pain is it to do that final step of putting the last floor on, which is the first floor, and, you know, making it flush with the ground? I mean, well, with any tower or construction projects, you're going to be re-grading the land
所以我预计这种方法会在空间狭窄的城市地块上更多地出现。我想随着时间的推移，这种方法会被越来越多地使用。这就说得通了。所以我还有一个最后的问题。我想从下往上建造东西的好处在于，你从地面开始。所以你不需要计算建筑与地面的交界处在哪里。它自然而然就发生了。你知道的，但是把最后一步——也就是把作为第一层的最后一层安放上去，并使其与地面平齐——这个过程会有多麻烦？我的意思是，嗯，对于任何塔楼或建筑项目来说，你都得对土地进行重新平整。
anyway. So you're going to be taking away soil or adding soil and moving around, making sure that building sits flush. And I don't think it's fundamentally that different in this case. But it does bring up a good point in general about construction in this building in particular, because you look at this facade and it's got this kind of offset grid pattern, which I found kind of visually interesting. The windows don't exactly line up like you might expect, and that's clearly an intentional part of the design aesthetically, but I'm also convinced
无论如何，你都要移走土壤或添加土壤并进行搬运，确保建筑平稳落成。我不认为在这种情况下它有什么根本的不同。但它确实普遍提出了关于施工、特别是关于这座建筑的一个好观点，因为你看这个立面，它有一种交错的网格图案，我觉得这在视觉上相当有趣。窗户并不像你所预期的那样整齐对齐，这显然是美学设计上有意为之的一部分，但我同样确信……
it gives them this, you know, a little bit of wiggle room, a little bit of leeway so that things don't have to line up. And in fact, aren't supposed to line up exactly. And that's to me a really big part of any big project is like there are going to be mistakes made along the way. And there's going to be like little measurement errors that add up. And so part of the art is covering up those small mistakes and making it look like they're not there in the first place.
……这给了他们你知道的，一点缓冲的余地，一点游余，这样东西就不必非得对齐了。事实上，它们本来就不应该完全对齐。在我看来，这是任何大型项目非常重要的一部分，那就是在此过程中难免会犯错。总会有一些小的测量误差累积起来。所以艺术的一部分就是掩盖这些小错误，让人觉得它们一开始就不存在。
Totally. Yeah. And construction. If you've ever seen construction, you'd be amazed at how much they're solving in the moment as it's being put together. It's so cool. Well, this is awesome. I love this stuff and I can't wait to see a top-down
完全同意。是的。如果你看过施工现场，你一定会惊讶于他们在组装过程中当场解决掉了多少问题。太酷了。好吧，这太棒了。我太喜欢这些了，我等不及在未来的某个时候看到一座带有小腿的自上而下建造的建筑了。是的，它太可爱了。非常感谢你，科尔。这是……嘿，乔。嘿，罗曼。最近怎么样？一切都好。你知道的，这些小故事总是能让我开心。所以你给我们带来了什么？嗯，对于这个小故事，我想做的第一件事是给你放一段音频。好的。
construction building with little legs on it sometime in my future. Yeah, it is adorable. Thank you so much, Kurt. This is. Hey, Joe. Hey, Roman. How's it going? It's going well. You know, many has always make me happy. So what do you have for us? Well, for this mini, the first thing I want to do is play a clip for you. OK. It's of Amelia Clark. She's a British actress, perhaps best known from Game of Thrones. And this is a clip of her on Jimmy Kimmel doing a voice, doing a bit. I'd love to hear your American accent. Well, it was late. So my American accent kind of changed a little bit into Callie
那是艾米莉亚·克拉克的采访。她是一位英国女演员，可能最为人熟知的是出演了《权力的游戏》。这是她在吉米·金梅尔的节目中模仿某种口音、表演一段小品时的音频。我很想听听你的美国口音。嗯，当时挺晚的。所以我的美国口音有点变了，变得有点像山谷女孩卡莉……
from the Valley. It's like this whole situation. And the thing I want to focus on about this clip is not the Valley Girl Akset, which we should probably do a whole other story. Yeah. But it's about the likes, all of the likes she's peppering into her speech.
……那种整个状况。而我想要关注这段音频的重点，不是山谷女孩的口音（我们或许应该为此专门做一整期节目），而是那些“like”，她夹杂在讲话中的所有这些“like”。
Yeah, we have a really good time. I got so close to getting jotted by me like a $700 air conditioning unit Did you base that on someone you know? I like love Clueless Yeah, she's good at that. Yeah, she is uncannily good and as a person who grew up, you know Maybe a mile and a half from the valley. I think she has my number Because the thing is like is my weakness. I am a hardcore likeer.
对，我们玩得很开心。我差点被像一个价值700美元的空调那样的东西给……你是根据你认识的某个人来模仿的吗？我超级喜欢《独领风骚》是的，她很擅长那个。是的，她模仿得好得不可思议。作为一个你知道的，可能在距离山谷大约一英里半的地方长大的人，我觉得她把我拿捏得死死的。因为问题是，“like”是我的弱点。我是一个重度“like”使用者。
And to be clear, I don't just like pepper in the occasional like, because when I get tired, I do like the multiple machine gun likes. You know what I mean? Like, like, like, like, like, like, you know, but it turns out the word like as well as the phrase, you know, which I also just used, when used in this way are actually a very specific thing called filler words. I am intrigued. So tell me more about these filler words. Well, filler words or fillers, as they're often called in linguistics, are things like
为了说清楚，我不仅仅是偶尔夹杂一个“like”，因为当我累了的时候，我会像机关枪一样发射一连串的“like”。你知道我的意思吗？就像：like, like, like, like, like, like, 你懂的。但事实证明，“like”这个词，以及我刚刚也用过的“you know”这个短语，以这种方式使用时，实际上是一种非常具体的东西，叫做填充词。我很感兴趣。所以请告诉我更多关于这些填充词的事情。嗯，填充词或语缀（fillers），正如它们在语言学中经常被称为的那样，是一些诸如……
like kind of, you know, basically, I mean, and of course, the classic non-word fillers, your basic ums and us. And when we hear someone else use them, we tend to think of the person as somehow just not having it together or being dumb or vapid. But that's why I wanted to share this many with you, because it turns out filler words are not, in fact, something to be ashamed of. When we use them, we're not being idiots or at least not entirely. Instead, filler words actually serve a really important function.
……“kind of”（有点）、“you know”（你知道的）、“basically”（基本上）、“I mean”（我的意思是），当然还有经典的无意义填充词，也就是你最基本的“um”和“uh”。当我们听到别人使用它们时，我们往往会认为这个人不知怎么地脑子不清楚，或者很愚蠢、空洞。但这就是为什么我想和你们分享这个小故事的原因，因为事实证明，填充词其实并不是什么见不得人的东西。当我们使用它们时，我们并不是白痴，或者至少不完全是。相反，填充词实际上发挥着非常重要的作用。
So, the kind of first big thing I'd want to point out about filler words is that they're informative. They carry information that is useful to people. This is Nick Enfield. He is a professor of linguistics at the University of Sydney and author of the book How We Talk. And he says the reason fillers and filler words are so important is that most of the time when you're talking, you're talking with another person, you're having a conversation, it's this kind of creative act that you're participating in together. And so times moving fast, and in a way you need to do your part to cooperate with that person, don't waste the time too much. And at the same time, you know, you've
所以，关于填充词，我想指出的第一件大事是它们是有信息量的。它们承载着对人们有用信息。这位是尼克·恩菲尔德。他是悉尼大学的语言学家，也是《我们如何交谈》一书的作者。他说，填充词和语缀之所以如此重要，是因为大多数时候你在说话时，你是在和另一个人说话，你们在进行对话，这是你们共同参与的一种创造性行为。所以时间过得很快，在某种程度上，你需要尽到自己的责任去配合对方，不要太浪费时间。与此同时，你知道的，你……
got your own sort of selfish interests, you might want to continue to be the person talking. And so it's important to kind of have what we call traffic signals in the use of language. And by traffic signals, he means that we constantly have to send each other signs, letting the other person know where the conversation might be going, who should be talking when, all these little things that kind of regulate the flow of the pattern. And so there's a whole level of language, which is really about structuring language itself. That's interesting, because he's talking about filler words, almost like their body language, but unlike with body language, where I feel like I'm often aware that I'm doing it, and
……有你自己的某种自私利益，你可能想继续做那个说话的人。因此，在语言的使用中拥有我们所谓的“交通信号”是很重要的。所谓交通信号，他的意思是，我们必须不断向彼此发送信号，让对方知道对话可能会走向何方、谁该在什么时候说话，所有这些微小的东西都在某种程度上调节着语言模式的流动。因此，存在着一整层语言，它真正关乎的正是语言本身的结构。这很有趣，因为他谈论填充词的方式，几乎就像它们是肢体语言一样。但与肢体语言不同的是，在肢体语言中，我感觉自己通常意识到自己在这样做，并且……
I could rattle off, you know, kind of the rules of what each little movement means, I'm not so sure I could do that with filler words. Like it's maybe just a little more subconscious. No, yeah, totally. And once I tell you the rules of how filler words work and the different things you use them for, you're going to be like, Oh, God. Of course, that's how I use them. Okay.
……我可以脱口而出，你知道的，每一个小动作意味着什么规则，但我不太确定我对填充词也能做到这一点。就像它可能只是稍微更潜意识一点。不，是的，完全如此。一旦我告诉你填充词是如何运作的规则以及你用它们来做的事，你就会有一种“哦，天哪，当然，我就是这么用的”的感觉。好吧。
So let's help me break this down. What are some of the rules that I don't know that I know? So just take something like um and for example, the classics, which of course are serving the practical function of giving you a moment to think of what to say next, which is something that is inevitable. All people in all cultures have a version of this because none of us are perfect. But there's all these other things that um, and uh, do for us. For example, it's also letting the other person know that you are going to pause so they
所以，来帮我剖析一下。有哪些规则是我不知道自己其实知道的？所以只需举个“um”和“uh”的例子，也就是经典用法，它们当然发挥着实际功能，那就是给你一点时间来思考接下来要说什么，这是不可避免的。所有文化中的所有人都有这种变体，因为我们都不完美。但“um”和“uh”还为我们做了所有这些其他事情。例如，它也让对方知道你将要停顿，这样他们……
don't jump in. And it turns out the length of the pause you're requesting is actually different depending on whether you say um or uh, uh, uh, precedes a shorter pause. And if you think about it, um, precedes a pause that is just a little bit longer. Huh. That makes sense to me. Another thing is you might have noticed that you're more likely to use, uh, or, um, if you want to signal to the other person that you're about to abruptly change the subject.
……就不会插话。事实证明，你所要求的停顿长度实际上是不同的，这取决于你说的是“um”还是“uh”。“uh”在较短的停顿之前出现。如果你仔细想想，“um”之前的停顿会稍微长那么一点点。哈。这对我来说说得通。另一件事是，你可能已经注意到，如果你想向对方发出信号，表明你即将生硬地转换话题，你更有可能使用“uh”或“um”。
Oh, yeah. Definitely. I've done that before. It's sort of like, um, how's your partner doing? Right. And, uh, your, um, gives me just enough buffer so the change isn't too jargain. And similarly, um, and, uh, also to bad news, so you're not too shocked. So I might deploy a well placed before I tell you, um, we broke up.
哦，是的。绝对的。我以前做过那种事。这就有点像：“嗯……你伴侣最近怎么样？”对吧。你的那个“um”给了我足够的缓冲，所以转变不会显得太唐突。同样地，“um”和“uh”也用于不好的消息，这样你就不会太震惊。所以我可能会在我告诉你“嗯……我们分手了”之前，巧妙地安插一个“well”。
Yeah, okay. I'm starting to see how these are, um, kind of useful traffic signals, you know, but what about the filler words that are also ordinary words, like kind of and like and you know. Well, so a lot of those are what Nick would call demonstratives. And demonstratives can work like a manate. They can serve a similar function, but you can also use them to help you listen or kind of put together what it is you're trying to convey, especially when what you're conveying has a lot of moving parts.
好吧，我开始明白这些是如何成为……嗯……某种有用的交通信号了，你知道的。但是那些本身也是普通词汇的填充词呢，比如“kind of”、“like”和“you know”？嗯，所以其中很多正是尼克所说的“指示词”（demonstratives）。指示词可以像操作杆一样工作。它们可以发挥类似的功能，但你也可以用它们来帮助你倾听，或者把你试图传达的内容拼凑起来，尤其是当你传达的内容包含很多活动部件时。
And perhaps my favorite example of a demonstrative providing this kind of structural support is one that isn't really used anymore, but it's a word found in that kind of old-fashioned tough guy gangster talk, which if you've ever seen like a James Cagney movie, you know this word. And not surprisingly, it's also been highly parodied as in this clip here. Wait a second, I'm not true. Understand? That one should be resurrected. That's pretty good. Definitely, definitely should be reintroduced. And in that case, you can kind of hear how the demonstrative word understand is underscoring
也许我最喜欢的关于指示词提供这种结构支持的例子是一个已经不再真正使用的词，但它是一种在那种老派硬汉黑帮片中可以找到的词。如果你看过詹姆斯·卡格尼的电影，你就会知道这个词。毫不奇怪，它也遭到了高度恶搞，就像下面这段剪辑里这样。等一下，我不懂。明白吗？那个词应该被重新启用。这挺不错的。绝对、绝对应该重新引入。在这种情况下，你可以听到指示词“understand”（明白）是如何在强调……
each separate element of this kind of complex scene so that you can kind of piece it all together. But also, like a lot of demonstrators understand, when used in this way, also still retains some of its original meaning. So you can sort of tell where those words have come from, and there's an argument that they kind of carry that meaning into the interaction, but that meaning is what we call bleached. Because once you start to use a word over and over, then more frequently you use it,
……这种复杂场景中的每一个独立元素，这样你就可以把它们全部拼凑在一起。但同时，就像许多指示词“understand”一样，当以这种方式使用时，它仍然保留了部分原始含义。所以你可以看出这些词来自哪里，有一种观点认为它们把这种含义带入了互动中，但这种含义是我们所说的“褪色”（bleached）。因为一旦你开始一遍又一遍地使用一个词，你使用的频率越高……
the less meaning it tends to carry. Yeah, that makes sense to me. I'm trying to think, what is my kids' filler word? There's the one that they use all of it. Oh, there's the phrase to be honest. And I am sure that when they say to be honest, they do not have meaning associated with it. Like, I feel like they've said it so much
……它所承载的含义往往就越少。是的，这对我来说说得通。我在想，我孩子们的填充词是什么？他们经常用的那个词。哦，有个短语叫“说实话”（to be honest）。我敢肯定，当他们说“to be honest”时，他们并没有赋予它任何含义。就像，我觉得他们说得太多了……
that it doesn't even, they don't even register it to themselves or that it has any meaning with, you know, at all. Like, it's just, it's used so frequently, it's kind of amazing. Right, so it's been bleached. Absolutely, bleached that of existence. But it makes me wonder, I mean, like, is it common in other languages
……以至于它甚至……他们甚至没有意识到它有任何含义，或者它根本没有任何意义。就像，它被用得太频繁了，这简直太惊人了。对，所以它已经褪色了。绝对的，褪色得不复存在了。但这让我纳闷，我是说，在其他语言中，拥有这些非常复杂的填充词甚至是填充短语，是很常见的事吗？哦，当然。请允许我把你的注意力吸引到维基百科的多语言填充词对照表上。
to have these like really complex filler words, and filler phrases even? Oh my yes. Allow me to direct your attention to the comparative language filler word Wikipedia. Oh, goodness gracious, okay, there we go. Oh my God. And so you can see there's all kinds of sounds
哦，天哪，好吧，就是这样。哦天哪。所以你可以看到有各种各样的声音、词语和短语被用作填充词。所有的语言都有它们，但每种语言（这才是最有趣的部分）都会以其独特的方式来使用它们。好吧，所以我看到在阿拉伯语里，有一个类似于“以神之名”的词，你知道的，就像“Wala”。还有一个类似于“叫什么来着”的填充短语……这有点神奇。我太喜欢了。哦，在乌尔都语里，有一种类似于“巴拉巴拉”或“诸如此类”的表达。
and words and phrases that are used as filler. All languages have them, but each language, this is the fun part, kind of does it in its own way. Okay, so I see like in Arabic, there's one for like by God, you know, like Wala. There's like, what's its name? As a filler phrase, That's kind of amazing. I love it. Oh, in Urdu, there's kind of a blah, blah, blah, or yada, yada, kind of thing.
这是一个好例子。然后阿根廷西班牙语里有“Che”，就像“喂”一样，它甚至成了埃内斯托·切·格瓦拉的绰号。哇。这可真是一个冷知识。这就是这个小故事的最后一个事实。我太喜欢这个了。美国手语里有一个表示“um”的符号，你知道的，正如它所说，可以用一个张开的数字8的手势放在下巴前，手掌朝下，眉头紧锁来打出这个手语。嗯，手语里竟然也内置了这种东西，真的挺神奇的。
That's a good one. And then Argentinian Spanish has a Che, like, hey, which they, which became the nickname of Ernesto Che Guevara. Wow. Because he used it so much. Well, that's a, that's a tidbit right there. That is the final fact of this of this mini. I love this. This American sign language. That there's a symbol for um, you know, just to, you know, like it says, it can be signed with an open eight held at the chin palm and eyebrows down. Um, it's really kind of amazing that they have that built into sign language as well.
是的，我确实去查了那个张开的8是指什么以及它是如何运作的。为了不让我们的观众去费力想象太具体的画面，它非常非常类似于把手指放在下巴上，然后低头沉思的样子。是的，所以，我明白“um”和“uh”有一些地区特异性，但它们几乎是普遍存在的，许多填充词也是如此。但在我的一生中，我见证了“like”的崛起。那是怎么发生的呢？一个新的填充词是如何凭空出现，而像“understand”这样的旧词又是如何消亡的呢？这对我来说简直太神奇了。是的，这实际上是一个非常难回答的问题。首先，因为几千年来，显然没有任何录音，只有书面记录。
Yeah, and I did have to look that up what the open aid is and how that works. Without making our audience try to visualize anything to specific, it's very, very similar to holding your finger to your chin and just kind of looking down and pondering. Yeah, so I get that the ums and us have some regional specificity, but they're pretty much universal and so are many of the filler words. But in my lifetime, I saw the ascendancy of like, and how does that happen? How does a new one crop up and an old one like understand, go away? That to me is kind of amazing. Yeah, that actually turns out to be a really hard question to answer. First off, because for millennia, obviously there were no recordings, only written records.
而且就像今天一样，没有人会把填充词写下来。语言通常不是那样运作的，对吧？所以如果你仔细想想，你或许能在19世纪的较旧文本中看到更多的“er”和“um”。所以也许人们过去用得更多，但尼克说其实并没有太多的线索。但接下来事情变得有趣起来，并且与我们对填充词的强烈污名化联系在了一起，那就是还有另一位学者迈克尔·埃拉德（Michael Erard），他一直在翻阅书面记录。似乎情况是……还有另一位学者迈克尔·埃拉德，他一直在翻阅书面记录。
And just like today, no one writes down the fillers. That's not how the language usually works, right? So you can maybe see some more ears and arms, you know, kind of in older texts, if you think about it, from the 19th century. So maybe people use those more, but Nick says there's not actually a lot of clues. But here's where things kind of get interesting and connect back up to this intense stigma we have against filler words, which is that there's another scholar, Michael Erard, who's been looking through the written records. And it seems to be the is that there's another scholar, Michael Aeroard, who's been looking through the written records.
似乎情况是，直到录音技术的出现，人们才开始大量抱怨填充词。是的，是的，一旦我们听到自己一遍又一遍地说这些词，我们就会对它们变得非常敏感，但当它们在实时发生且没有被录音时，我们甚至根本注意不到。对。完全正确。我实际上和尼克谈过这件事。
And it seems to be the case that it's only with the advent of recorded sound that lots of people start to complain about fillers in the first place. Yeah, yeah, once we hear ourselves saying these words over and over again, we get so conscious about them, but we don't even notice them when they're happening in real time and not being recorded. Right. Exactly. And I actually spoke with Nick about this.
他是这样解释的。关于广播、录音、播客以及所有这些东西，有一点值得指出，那就是这是一种体验语言的方式，而你并没有参与到对话中。你不是一个参与者。你只是坐在那里倾听。现在，如果你想想乡村生活，某种意义上，你总是那种社会情况的一部分，那些将是你的邻居，将是你的家庭成员，而且你随时可能加入到那个对话中。但是当你开始听声音……
And he kind of explained it this way. One thing that's worth pointing out about radio and sound recording and podcasts and all of that is that it's a way of experiencing language where you're not involved in the conversation. You're not a participant. You're just sitting back and hearing it. Now, if you think about village life, in some sense, you're not a participant, you're just sitting back and hearing it. Now, if you think about a village life, in some sense, you're always part of that social situation, those are going to be your neighbors, they're going to be your family members, and you're going to potentially jump into that conversation at any point. But when you start listening to sound
……广播中的录音以及诸如此类的东西时，那种联系就完全被切断了。所以你拥有了一种奇怪的奢侈，能够只去研究你正在听的语言，因为你不需要去追踪你接下来可能要说些什么。这就解释了为什么听充满“um”和“like”的录音会稍微有点枯燥，因为你不在那里参与对话、等待插话或者知道你什么时候该说点什么。它没有提供那种结构。
recordings on radio and that kind of thing, that connection is completely severed. So you have this kind of weird luxury of being able to just study the language you're listening to because you don't have to track what you're going to maybe say next. And this sort of explains why it's a little more tedious to listen to a recording of lots of ums and likes because you're not there in a conversation waiting to jump in or know when you're supposed to say anything. Like, it's not providing that structure.
它是作为一个录音呈现给你的。这让它们变得稍微有点枯燥。没错。因此，突然之间，如果你是听众，你就会变得有点不耐烦。你会说，你为什么一直在说这些“um”、“uh”和“kind of”？这对毫无用处。说重点。是的。所以正是随着录音技术、广播和留声机的出现……
It is being presented to you as a recording. And it makes them a little more tedious. Right. And so suddenly, if you're the listener, you're going to be kind of impatient. You're going to say, why are you saying all these ums and us and sort ofs? That's of no use to me. Like, get to the point. Yeah. And so it is with the advent of recorded sound and the radio and the phonograph, right?
……诸如此类的东西，你开始看到大量关于在所谓的“规范语言”中避免填充词的书籍和文章。但这其实也与我们在节目中所做的事情紧密相连，几乎在任何广播播客节目中也是如此，那就是从采访中删掉大量的填充词。是的。我以前从未有意识地这样想过，但我认为这部分是因为我们与观众契约的一部分，就是我们要为他们准备一些稍微打磨过的内容。是的，但话说回来，如果填充词的全部意义在于提供这种对话结构，而它又不是真正的对话，那么也许除了仅仅感到恼火或……
And things like that, that you start to see lots of books and articles about avoiding filler words in quote unquote, proper speech. But it really also ties into what we do here on the show, and pretty much on any radio podcast program, which is to take out lots of filler words from interviews. Yeah. And I've never kind of consciously thought about it this way before, but I think it's in part because part of our contract with the audience is that we are preparing something a little polished for them. Yeah, but also like if the whole point of the filler word is to provide that conversational structure and it's not really a conversation, then maybe there's a good, sort of base reason rather than just being annoyed or, you know, find them tedious.
……觉得它们枯燥之外，还有一个很好的、基础的理由（来删掉它们）。我的意思是，把它们删掉确实有充分的理由。我的意思是，我摆脱了大量的填充词。我认为这只是我们出于对被采访者的慷慨而做的事情，为了让他们听起来像他们在脑子里想的那样完美。是的。而事实上，我的意思是，你知道的，稍微拉开一点帷幕，“别担心，我们会让你听起来很棒”这句话……
Like, there's a good reason to take them out. I mean, I get rid of a ton of them. I think of it as just a thing that we're doing, you know, out of generosity to the interview we to make it sound as polished as they probably sound in their head. Yeah. And that is, in fact, I mean, you know, just to pull the curtain back a little bit, the phrase, don't worry, we'll make you sound really good. It is.
……在我担任广播制作人的职业生涯中，已经帮我搞定了一半的采访。所以，当你把这段采访剪辑成你的微故事时，我会相信你会让我听起来还不错。不作任何承诺。不，没关系。我会相信你会让我听起来还不错。不作承诺。不，没关系的，我开玩笑呢。当然，一如既往，我们会让你听起来非常棒。乔，非常感谢你带来这些。这真的太迷人了。
It has, has booked me half my interviews in my time as a radio producer. So when you take this conversation and you cut it down into your mini story, I'm going to trust that you're going to make me sound okay. No promises. No, that's all right. I'm going to trust that you're going to make me sound okay. No promises. No, that's alright, I'm just kidding. Of course, as always, we will make you sound really good. Joe, thank you so much for this. This was super fascinating.
不客气，罗曼，这是我的荣幸。接下来是一场已经燃烧了且将燃烧几十年的地下大火，以及想象一下住在它旁边会是什么感觉。一个音乐微故事。广告之后见。所以我今天请到了创作型歌手莉兹。嘿，莉兹。嘿，罗曼。
You're welcome Roman, it was my pleasure. Coming up an underground fire that has burned and will burn for decades and imagining what it would be like to live next to it. A musical mini story. After this. So I'm here with singer-songwriter Lizzie. No, hey Lizzie. Hey Roman.
如你所知，我是你作品的超级粉丝。我看过你很多次演出，其中有一次我看到你表演时，你唱了一首名叫《森特拉利亚》（Centrelia）的歌，我非常喜欢。它有一个非常引人入胜的背景故事，非常具有《99%隐形》的风格。所以我希望你能给我们讲讲这个故事。我的歌《森特拉利亚》是一首虚构歌曲，取材于1962年在宾夕法尼亚州森特拉利亚爆发的一场煤矿大火的真实故事。我们并不确定是什么引发了这场火灾。有些人说市政府负有责任，因为为了准备阵亡将士纪念日，他们在焚烧垃圾以清理小镇。有些人认为这是天灾或是一个谜。但无论起因是什么，火灾始于5月27日……
I'm a huge fan of your work as you know And I've seen you play lots of times and one of times I saw you play you play the song called Centrelia which I love and it has a very fast name back story very 99 PI back story So I was hoping you could tell us that story my song centrelia is a fictional song based on a true story about a coal fire that broke out in Centralia, Pennsylvania in 1962. We don't know for sure what caused the fire. Some people say that the city government was responsible because they were burning trash to clean up the town in preparation for Memorial Day. Some people think it was an act of God or a mystery. But whatever the cause was, the fire started on May 27th
……并蔓延到了小镇下方数英里交错的煤矿隧道。由于煤炭的存在，那里面有大量被压缩的碳，所以这场大火一直无法被扑灭。科学家们认为，它可能会继续燃烧另外250年。这场火灾始于1962年。
and connected with the miles and miles of coal mining tunnels that were underneath the town. There is a lot of compressed carbon down there because of the coal, so the fire was never able to be extinguished. And scientists think that it could continue to burn for another 250 years. This is the fire started in 1962,
它仍在燃烧，并且此后还将燃烧200年，我想。疯狂的是，是的。这场大火在50多年后仍在燃烧，它导致整个城市出现了一个个天坑，并使其变得彻底不宜居住。有故事说，人们的宠物掉进天坑里消失了，孩子们也掉了进去。所以这个小镇自然而被疏散了，因为城市下方布满了天坑构成的雷区。人口迅速从大约1500人锐减到只剩下大约5人……
it's still burning, and will we burning henceforth for another 200 years. This is the fire started in 1962. It's still burning, and we'll be burning henceforth for another 200 years, I think. Wildly enough, yes. The fire is still burning over 50 years later, and it has caused sinkholes to appear throughout the city and made it totally uninhabitable. There are stories of people's pets falling into a sinkhole and disappearing, kids falling in. So the town was naturally evacuated because there was this minefield of sinkholes underneath the city. And the population quickly went from about 1,500 to only about five residents that are
……留守在那里。那么你是怎么听到这个故事的呢？我有一位来自宾夕法尼亚州的好朋友，她也写歌，而且也是个奇怪的历史迷。所以她读到了关于这场大火的报道，并说：“我得给莉兹打电话”，因为她知道我对这个会有一种离奇的着迷。所以我立刻陷入了维基百科的疯狂搜索中，找到了我能弄到的一切资料，从第一手目击记到50年后森特拉利亚现状的环境报告。
left. And so how did you hear about this story? I have a good friend from Pennsylvania who also writes songs and is also kind of a weird history nut. So she read about this fire and said, I need to call Lizzie because she knew I would be bizarrely fascinated by it. So I immediately went down to Wikipedia rabbit hole and found everything I could possibly get my hands on from first hand accounts to environmental reports on the situation in Centralia 50 years later.
……50年后森特拉利亚现状的环境报告。这实际上是一个非常迷人的科学环境。尽管这场实验并非有意为之，但它基本上就像一个非军事区，野生动物重新占领了整个小镇，大自然又把这里夺了回去。所以从多个角度来看，整个事情都非常迷人。
environmental reports on the situation in Centralia 50 years later. It's actually a really fascinating scientific environment. Even though the experiment wasn't intentional, it's basically like a demilitarized zone where wildlife has reclaimed this whole city and nature has just taken it back over. So the whole thing is fascinating from a number of angles.
我无法停止思考的是，而且没有任何报告提到的一点，是对以下情景的描述：成为那五个拒绝撤离、至今仍基本生活在鬼城里的人之一，究竟会是什么样的体验和感受。所以我最终写出来的这首歌，基本上只是我在想象，当你的整个城市被毁、你的社区被疏散后，一个人在多年以后会处于一种怎样的心境。而且你眼睁睁看着可能发生的最糟糕的事情发生在了自己身上。这首歌叫做《森特拉利亚》，我想把它弹给大家听，因为我太喜欢它了……
What I couldn't stop thinking about and what wasn't in any of the reports was a description of what it actually would be like and feel like to be one of those five people that refuse to evacuate and is still basically living in a ghost town. So the song that I ended up writing was basically just me imagining the state of mind that someone would be in years and years later, after your entire city has been destroyed, your community has been evacuated. And you've watched the absolute worst thing that could possibly happen, happen to you. And the song is called Centrelia and I want to play it for everybody because I love it,
……就是这样。你想看太阳升起吗？坐在我家后面的草丛里？盯着那些飞得太低、就像瞄准地面的飞机瞄准地面 瞄准地面你想在中间与我相遇吗？在森特拉利亚，那里的火永远不会熄灭我们会原封不动地找到我们的东西在地下燃烧，在地下燃烧
and here it is. Do you want to watch the sun come up? Sitting in the weeds behind my house? Keep our eyes on the plains that fly too low like they're aiming for the ground Aiming for the ground And do you want to meet me in the middle? A centrelia where the fire can't go out We'll find our things exactly where we left them Burning underground, burning underground
我们总会闯过去的那些把我们吓个半死的恐惧它们现在伤害不了我们它们现在伤害不了我们它们现在伤害不了我们我已经在车道上站了十年看着葡萄藤吞噬着公路大约一个月前我下定决心要拔掉桩子，大约一个月前我推着你闭上眼睛，一切开始下沉。
We'll make it out somehow And the things that scared us have to death They can't hurt us now They can't hurt us now They can't hurt us now Ten years I've been standing in the driveway Watching the grapefines eating up the road And I made up my mind to pull the stakes up about a month ago, about a month ago. I push it close your eyes and everything starts sinking.
听听寒冷的噼啪声。等你走到前门时，高速公路只剩下一个洞，高速公路只剩下一个洞但你总归是闯过来了那些曾把你吓个半死的恐惧，它们现在伤害不了你了。它们现在伤害不了你了。曾经他们告诉我，当该逃跑的时候我自然会知道我在清晨的凉意中打退堂鼓我看到黑烟升起而我们总会闯过去的
Listen to the crackle of the cold. And by the time you make it out your front door, the highway's just a hole, the highway's just a hole But you only made it out somehow And the things that scared you have to death, they can't hurt you now. They can't hurt you now. Ever they told me I was gonna know when it was time to run I had cold feet in the cool of the morning And I saw the black smoke rising up And we'll make it out somehow
那些把我们吓个半死的恐惧，它们现在伤害不了我们它们现在伤害不了我们你想在中间与我相遇吗？我在森特拉利亚，那里的火永远不会熄灭？我们会原封不动地找到我们的东西在地下燃烧在地下燃烧在地下燃烧在地下燃烧在地下燃烧这就是由我的嘉宾莉兹带来的歌曲《森特拉利亚》。那是出自你的第一张专辑，对吧？没错，我的第一张专辑《Hard One》。我太喜欢那张专辑了。谢谢你。不过，我最激动的不是你的老专辑，虽然我喜欢那张专辑。谢谢你。而且，我最激动的不是你的老专辑，虽然我很喜欢并且经常听……
And the things that scared us have to death, they can't hurt us now. They can't hurt us now. Do you want to meet me in the middle? I send trail you where the fire can't go out? We'll find our things exactly where we left them Burning underground them burning underground Burning underground burning underground Burning underground So that was a song centralia by my guest Lizzy now that was off your first album right? Correct my first album hard one. I love that album. Thank you What I'm most excited though is not your old albums although I love that album. Thank you. And what I'm most excited, though, is not your old albums, although I love and listened
……你的老专辑。根据某个知名的音乐流媒体服务，你是我今年的顶级艺术家之一，和The National、泰勒·斯威夫特以及所有有菲比·布里杰斯参与的项目齐名。一定要把这段尖叫保留进去。哦，哦，我会的。但我不仅为你过去的音乐感到兴奋。我很高兴你有一张新专辑即将问世。1月19日，请在日历上做好标记。
to your old albums regularly. You're one of my top artists of the year, according to one notable streaming service, along with the National and Taylor Swift and every project featuring Phoebe Bridgers. Make sure you keep that scream in. Oh, oh, I will. But I'm not just excited about your old music. I'm excited that you have a new album, which is coming out imminently. January 19th, Mark your calendar.
经常听你的老专辑。根据某个知名的流媒体服务，你是我的年度顶级艺人之一，同行的还有The National、泰勒·斯威夫特以及所有有菲比·布里杰斯参与的项目。确保把那声尖叫留着。哦，哦，我会的。但我不仅为你以前的音乐感到兴奋。我很兴奋你有一张新专辑，即将问世。1月19日，记下你的日历。
I have a new album coming out. It's called Half Seas, coming out on 30 Tigers and my own label, Miss Freedom Land. I am so pumped. You're going to be touring with it. I already have tickets to see you in Marin and I'm so excited. So tell me a little bit about the album and what is going on with your album. This new album is a concept album that I like to imagine as a video game. The character is an avatar of me or maybe you or maybe anyone who's listening,
我有一张新专辑要发行，名叫《Half Seas》，将通过 30 Tigers 和我自己的厂牌 Miss Freedom Land 发行。我太兴奋了。你要带着它去巡演。我已经买票去马林郡看你的演出了，我太激动了。所以跟我讲讲这张专辑，以及你的专辑现在进展如何。这张新专辑是一张概念专辑，我想象它就像一款视频游戏。主角是我的化身，也可能是你，或者任何正在收听节目的听众，
trying to get free in America. And there's 11 stories of like self-discovery, fighting for your life, finding your allies, sharpening your knives, and heading for freedom. That's amazing, I can't wait for it. And we're gonna play a song from the new album and let people enjoy that. And then they will rush over to where to go buy it.
试图在美国获得自由。这里有11个关于自我发现、为生存而战、寻找盟友、磨砺利刃以及奔向自由的故事。太棒了，我等不及了。我们将播放新专辑中的一首歌，让大家欣赏。然后他们就会冲去购买。
30 Tigers or Rough Trade, if you want a vinyl record, I'm also gonna be touring all over the US and Europe. So, LizzyNo.com slash tour dates. Awesome. It was so great to have you here. Thank you, Lizzy. Thank you so much for having me. This is the song, Any Oakley. If I'm my guest, Lizzy No. A new album, Half Seas.
30 Tigers 或 Rough Trade，如果你想要一张黑胶唱片的话。我还在美国和欧洲各地巡演。网址是 LizzyNo.com 斜杠 tour dates。太棒了。很高兴你能来到这里。谢谢你，莉齐。非常感谢邀请我。这首歌是《Any Oakley》。我的嘉宾是莉齐·诺。新专辑《Half Seas》。
There's a ringing in my ear and it's hot as hell here at the annual cleat. Feel dirt between the sheets, perforated by the end of a cigarette. There's nothing on TV, and I'm thinking to myself Maybe I should get some sleep I should get some sleep I've got half a bottle left Oh come on inside Sit in my feet
我的耳朵里在嗡嗡作响，年度球鞋展这里热得像地狱。床单间能感受到泥土，被烟头烫出了孔洞。电视上什么也没有，我在想也许我该睡一会儿我该睡一会儿我还剩半瓶哦快进来坐在我的脚边
I sit in my feet Won't you tell me when it's time to kill the dream? We drove up to the edge At least it felt like the end of the world We were outside Kansas City Loosen on the radio I'm counting out my tears Is it enough for half a tank? Cause the black girls that are moving along
我坐在我的脚边你难道不能告诉我什么时候该扼杀这个梦想吗？我们开车来到边缘至少感觉像是世界的尽头我们在堪萨斯城外收音机里播放着慢歌我在数着我的眼泪这够加满半箱油吗因为那些搬走的黑女孩
When the sun goes down in this part of the country Waiting by the side of the highway The artist is Lizzie Know, the new album is called Half Seas. She is the best. We should all make her the next modern country superstar. We'll have links to everything about her on our website and in the show. 99% of the Vizbo was produced this week by Kurt Colestay, Jacob Moltenano Medina, Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, and Sarah Beak. Mixed by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rihall. Kathy too is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is the senior editor. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Jason Dillion, Washington, Madonna, Kelly Prime, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below goat was created by Stefan Lawrence.
当这个国家这部分的太阳落下时在高速公路旁等待艺术家是莉齐·诺，新专辑名为《Half Seas》。她是最棒的。我们都应该让她成为下一个现代乡村音乐巨星。我们将在网站和节目中提供关于她的一切链接。本周的 99% Vizbo 由库尔特·科尔斯泰、雅各布·莫尔特纳诺·梅迪纳、克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格和萨拉·比克制作。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里霍尔创作音乐。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，德兰尼·霍尔是高级编辑。团队其他成员包括埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·利、杰森·狄龙、华盛顿、麦当娜、凯利·普莱姆以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99% 的他的山羊由斯特凡·劳伦斯创造。
We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. If your New Year's resolution is to spend less time doom scrolling on a social media site, why don't you replace that impulse with some positive scrolling on our website. It's 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 Stitcher 和 Serious XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。非常美丽。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市区。如果你更新年的决心是减少在社交媒体网站上无休止刷屏的时间，为什么不把这种冲动替换为在我们网站上进行一些积极的浏览呢。网址是 99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。